oh hi there well you've just caught me
reading the latest edition of celebrity
spectacular my favorite magazine in the
world but not really you'll notice on
the front there a picture of Justin
Bieber the latest teen heartthrob pop
star thing in fact this magazine is
almost completely dedicated to mr.
Justin Bieber is obviously quite popular
and when I was flicking through it one
of the first pages that caught my
attention was this quiz do you have and
Bieber fever so I've decided that I'm
going to try and find out let's see if I
have Bieber fever I have more than 15
posters of justed on my wall um well
actually I only got 14 so I guess no my
friends and I know all of Justin's dance
moves yeah I do
actually here's an example yes so yes to
that one I already have a Bieber
birthday party planned for his special
day March the 1st Justin Bieber's
birthday was on March the 1st oh man I
missed it I tell people that my last
name is Bieber hey what's your first
name
oh yes charlie and your last name Bieber
do you have any middle name sir yeah
I've got three actually um I love him I
spend several hours a day looking at
Justin's YouTube videos I actually spent
my time watching videos like this so no
and apparently that leaves me with
having a mild case of Bieber fever
you totally dig Justin sounds but you're
not totally obsessed with him yet
although you think it would be awesome
to meet him one day you also love other
celebs like Taylor Lautner Taylor
Lautner who's she seriously though I
think this magazine is making a big
mistake assuming that I have any kind of
Bieber fever at all I mean obviously the
posters will tell you another story but
really when it comes down to it I just
don't don't get me wrong I mean I
haven't got anything against Justin
Bieber I mean sure he looks really
stupid in that hat that is obviously way
too big for him and he looks equally
stupid doing that stupid hand heart sign
but really what I've learned from this
thing is that he seems like a nice guy
you know he likes his mum man he's very
grateful for his pop star lifestyle but
something that does scare me is what you
can find in magazines like this let me
give you a few examples there's one page
that has an obsession with just
smile justin's natural smile means he's
having fun
justin's deep in thought when he's
biting his lip there's another entire
page dedicated to his hair justin's hair
close-up justin makes the girl swoon
with his signature hair flip personally
I'm not attracted to Justin Bieber but
even for people who are I mean I don't
think that particular image is gonna
make any girls swim I mean you can't
even see his face and his face is the
best bit in my opinion true fans can
still recognize Jay under a hat or
hoodie
okay wait is this seriously implying
that only a true fan can recognize
Justin Bieber when he's wearing a hat or
a hoodie you don't need to be a Justin
Bieber fan in order to recognize his
face this last page basically insinuates
that he's single he's looking for love
and that he would date a fan uh I mean
this is the page that just wants to
exploit the crushes that teenage girls
have on Justin Bieber to the end to
grade and it just really I don't know it
just makes me a bit sad more than
anything
if you have any thoughts on Bieber fever
or just kind of the notion of celebrity
in general let me know because it's
quite an interesting topic and I'd like
to hear from you and I'll see you next
time here on whatever this is that I'm
doing with my time goodbye you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool
Oh